i happened to be on css tricks the other
day and when i saw this animated card
list i thought
wow that's a cool css trick so in
today's beginner-friendly tutorial we're
going to reverse engineer this ui
element using nothing but html and css
over the next few minutes you'll learn
how to combine both grid and flexbox
layout to position the cards
we'll use transforms and shadows to make
it look like the cards are stacked on
top of each other we'll implement some
transition animations and i'll throw in
a few other tricks
like a gradient text background and svg
styles for this little semi-circle under
the avatar if you're new here like and
subscribe and you can find the full
source code for this project on github
and follow along with the write up on
fireship io
we're going to build this feature step
by step from scratch so pull up your
editor
and create a file called card.css and
index.html
in your html type an exclamation point
followed by tab
to create the initial boilerplate then
in the head of the document
type in link to access the snippet for a
css link and then point it to your
card.css file and the body of the
document we'll add a section this will
be the main container for the card list
then each individual card will be
represented by an article element
we'll add a header to each individual
card and later in the video we'll come
back and add an avatar
and some tags now rather than target
these elements directly i'm going to add
a class name to each element then i'm
going to copy and paste our markup so we
have multiple cards to work with and
just a friendly reminder
it's much easier to copy and paste this
markup from github
now one quick thing i want to point out
is that instead of a section article and
header i could have just called
all these elements divs this would work
perfectly fine but when you write html
you want to use semantic elements where
you can or in other words use elements
that clearly define what the content is
all about
in any case we can open up our html by
right-clicking on the file and clicking
copy path
then we can paste that into the browser
and you should get a result that looks
like this
and now we're ready to start
implementing some css tricks at the top
of the file i'm going to import a google
font
then i'll add some global styles to the
body tag like a dark background and
setting that font family as the default
font
and our ui is already looking much
better currently the cards are flowing
vertically but we want them to flow
horizontally we can make that happen by
setting display flex on our card list
which by default will place the items
into a row
in other words it'll take all the cards
in the list and adjust their width
according to the available space in the
container we call that a flexible row
and of course you can learn more about
it in my 100 seconds of flexbox video
and then we'll add a little bit of
padding to that container as well that
takes care of our row
now we can think of each individual card
as a column within that row
so we'll also give that a display of
flex we'll set its position to relative
and then the flex direction to column to
make any content inside the card
flow vertically we want each card to
have the same height and width
so we can use fixed pixel values there
then we'll set the min width to 250.
if we have a bunch of cards in the
container we don't want them to get
squeezed too small
instead we'll let them flow to their
minimum width and then we'll let the
overflow scroll horizontally
now our cards are in a scrollable
container but it's hard to tell when one
card finishes and the next one starts
one subtle yet powerful way to address
that is to give each card some shadow
first we'll use border radius to round
the edges then we'll give it a
background color
and then we can set a box shadow and
notice how the first value
is negative this little trick will put
the shadow on the right side of the box
which makes the card on the right
look like it's hovering above the card
on the left that's because that first
value represents the horizontal offset
of the shadow but notice how the scroll
bar on the card list is really ugly
let's go ahead and address that now
we'll want to set its overflow x
property to scroll and then we have
three pseudo elements that we can style
we can give the scroll bar itself a
width and height of 10 pixels then the
scroll bar thumb
is the thing the user actually drags
around we'll give it a background
radius and we'll give it a box shadow
with an inset value
which puts the shadow on the inside of
the element and lastly we have the
scroll bar track which will give a
background with a linear gradient and
now our scroll bar is much nicer looking
but just keep in mind that the scroll
bar sudo elements aren't supported on
every browser so don't expect this to
look good on every device
and that brings us to the next trick the
animation when we hover
over the cards watch the animation
closely when we hover over a card
it moves up by a few pixels then all of
the siblings that come after it
move to the right while all the siblings
before it stay put
we'll start by grabbing the card that's
actually hovered by using the hover
pseudo selector
we'll then use transform to move or
translate that card along the y
axis by negative one rem that will move
it in an upward direction
equal to the root font size which is
about 15 pixels in our case
that's easy enough but the tricky part
here is selecting all the children
that come after the hovered card when a
card has focus or when it's hovered
we'll use the tilde character to select
all of the elements that are siblings
that come after it with the card class
it's called the general sibling
combinator and it grabs all the children
after the element
but not the element itself or any of the
siblings before it after selecting those
elements we can then use transform to
translate or move those elements across
the x-axis
by 130 pixels and as a final touch we
need to grab every card element that's
not the first child in the list
and set its margin left to negative 130
to offset the transformation otherwise
there will be a big gap in between the
cards
not is called the negation pseudo class
it basically does the opposite of
whatever you're telling it to do
or in our case grab every card that is
not the first card
at this point things are looking pretty
good but there's no timing in the
animation so it looks really jerky
we can address that by simply adding a
transition for 0.2 seconds in this case
to the card class now whenever a
property value changes on the card
it will take 0.2 seconds to translate
between the old value and the new value
that takes care of the main card stack
but i still have a few more tricks up my
sleeve
what i want to show you next is how we
can add an avatar along with this
semi-circle underneath it
to get that started we'll need to go
back into our html
then inside the card class below the
header we'll add a div for the card
author
inside of that element we'll add a link
for the author avatar
and inside that link we'll add an image
tag that points to an image i recently
added to the project
this can be any image that you want now
in order to add a half circle border to
the image
we need to add an svg graphic below it
you'll want to just copy this value from
the main source code
but basically it's just a single svg
graphic with a path
of a half circle and then below that
we'll add another div
with the author name as well as an
author name prefix to add some
additional styling there
currently everything looks very out of
whack so let's head back into our css
code
currently the card author lives inside
of a flex column
but there's no reason we can't make this
element a grid to display the elements
inside of it so that's exactly what
we'll do here by setting display to grid
we have the avatar image on the left
side and we want that container to
always be 75 pixels
so we can set the grid template columns
property to 75 for the first column
and then one fractional unit for the
next column to make that column
responsive
then we'll align the grid items to the
center and add some margin to it
from there we can move on to the image
element inside of the author avatar div
we'll want to make sure it's display
block because images are inline by
default
we'll give it a fixed width and height
and then set the border radius to 50
to make it appear as a circle then if
you want to turn it into a black and
white image
you can use filter along with the
grayscale value set to 100 percent
that puts the image in the right place
but now we need to move our svg
underneath it we can target the svg
directly with our half circle
class and we'll set its position to
absolute this allows us to move it
anywhere within the grid area
so let's move it to the bottom left we
can define the width and height
but it's currently displayed as a black
half circle what we actually want to do
is remove the fill color from the shape
so we set the fill property to none then
we give it a border by defining the
stroke property
the stroke has a color width and a line
cap value
which when set to round will give it a
rounded edge then as a final touch we'll
style the author name prefix class
to a bold light gray color that takes
care of our avatar section and now we're
ready for the final trick which answers
the question
how do we apply a css gradient to text
unfortunately
it's not as easy as just targeting the
color property when we try to apply a
linear gradient
to color you can see that nothing
happens what we actually need to do
is set the background of the element
then use the shape of the text to clip
the background
let's go ahead and change the color
property to background and then we'll
set the text shadow to none
then we'll use background clip to use
the text shape to essentially cut out
the background
we also need to use the webkit vendor
prefix for background clip
and text fill color set to transparent
this will allow the background color to
flow through the text shape
and now we have this cool gradient
effect when we hover over a header in
the card
just keep in mind that browser support
for this particular trick is fairly
limited
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe
and if you want access to more advanced
full stack content consider becoming a
pro member at fireship io
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one